you talk a lot about your crippling
anxiety and yet you have chosen this
form of Comedy which I would find to be
the most anxiety producing of all yeah
which is I pranks terrify me yeah you
know when I've been around them or when
when people have wanted me to sort of
participate in a prank I've been
terrified really Something's Gonna go
wrong you exude confidence uh also
you're so giant you're like Paul Bunyan
I can't imagine you you Howard and Sasha
Baron Cohen are so gigantic you guys
just all exude confidence down there but
it's also you're just so high up there
that it's like but it's like but it's
but the personality is formed when
you're young and Afraid and uh your
brothers are beating the out of you
and that's when the personality is
formed and it never changes and you're
going to school with carrot red hair and
two front teeth that are dead and
freckles and um and you don't have two
front teeth that are dead I did when I
was a little kid my I fell in the
driveway and my two front teeth died and
my parents said well you know dentists
back then were like leave them in the
other ones will come out in a few years
and so I walked around these two gray
teeth in front that looked like corn
that had rotted you were like a chimney
sweep yes 19th century and I had a whole
haircut that my mother insisted on I
look like the Wendy's girl on crack you
know and I'd stumble around
people are tough there yeah and so
um there was a lot of running away uh I
remember running away from people a lot
and
um pranks so pranks terrify you but but
what I'm saying is that pranks for a
person with anxiety how can I do such
anxiety provoking yes things
um
I think that's actually part of it and
I've talked to my therapist about it a
lot and I think it has
something to do I think my anxiety my
ADD am I OCD they're all they're all in
a band together they're all jamming out
together and I think the only time
uh
I feel alive
that was in my head but I didn't want to
say it I was like I can't say that like
I'm like the guitar player from
Aerosmith the only time I feel alive is
um when I'm doing something like that's
so high stakes and yes uh threatening my
life that it helps me Focus maybe that's
me trying to like but my favorite
my fear would not be that I would get
hurt my fear would be that someone else
might get hurt uh emotionally or
physically no no
um well both but but I'd be but
physically too like you're shooting
something or yeah or someone it's
supposed to look like someone got badly
hurt but they didn't but someone what if
someone else rushed in and then they got
hurt yeah I don't know I I that's that's
always the thing that's in my mind which
is well I don't think about it that much
yeah I go into it blind yeah well I
think it helps that you're a sociopath
my medulla is the size of a popcorn girl
when you were downstairs in the serious
building uh getting your quote pass we
also scanned your mind yes sociopath
yeah yeah you allowed entry you have no
uh frontal or lateral lobes yeah there's
just nothing there I'm like that guy
Phineas Gage I got a railroad spike
through oh my God know his name you knew
his name big Phineas Gage fan are you
kidding me I love his work I got his
albums this is the guy that accidentally
got a railroad spike in his head and
then lived for a long time right yeah so
he's like an early early 20th century
yeah yeah or maybe even late late 19th
century he got a railroad spike through
his frontal lobe question mark
and it didn't kill him but it like uh
changed his behavior and uh he thought
he was a choo choo train
you should say I'm leaving the station
Phineas okay all right no yeah he got
really cool after he got the original
Spike through his head it was like punk
rock it was like a body mod my God I can
imagine a guy like that getting all that
attention and then today he'd get a
whole bunch of attention
um on Instagram and he'd blow up and
everyone would be talking about Phineas
Gage and Spike through his head and I
know that two weeks later he'd see it
start to drop and so he'd say it's time
to have another piece of metal
in
a different direction and he'd be
instantly killed
go out
trending back then you could have a
whole lifetime being hey you're Phineas
Gage the guy that got a railroad spike
in the head high five me not anymore and
then it's like yeah no the spike thing
was cool but that's so 1998. yeah what
have you done lately the good old days
are behind us man you could just get one
railroad inspected ahead and you'd be on
Easy Street for the rest of your career
oh so so this leads my next question
have you ever done a sketch in Adult
Swim was like okay not not that one
we're not the only thing that we ever
cut we had a pro Al-Qaeda country song
that's the only one that it was like oh
sweet alcata can't believe I never tried
yo something like that and and what was
the point of view of this country singer
that you know Al qaeda's been it's been
enough we've been on them too
much and it's time for them to catch a
break yeah it was like there's a lot of
anti-al-qaeda sentiment they need like a
PR shake-up yeah and they so they have a
country song yeah so we had a country
singer could come in and sing a pro Al
Qaeda country song and they and they
it's the only thing they ever cut and
I'm like defecating on my desk every
other interview and they're like yeah no
problem right in front of celebrities
right have you had fully dilated have
you had celebrities uh walk out yeah
who's walked out
um the rapper T.I walked out and uh
Lauren Conrad the reality TV show from
Star Hills or something don't act like
you don't know come on we dated and then
we were married and then divorced then
remarried then divorced again that was a
long time ago that was weeks ago yeah
yeah so uh she walked out because she
didn't like the flavor of your question
um I vomited on the desk interview
I thought you slightly you put something
you phrased something in in a slightly
insulting way you misspoke and she
walked out no it's I vomited and then I
slurped the vomit back off okay that's
good I'll do it she didn't think that
was uh cool yeah a little too blue yeah
that type of humor yeah well so uh but I
apologized I had a guest my real
achievement was I had a guest walk out
before I even interviewed them which was
yeah he's a famous director Abel Farrar
and oh I know I love Abel yeah he's
genius and he showed up and he just had
a panic attack he was watching me on the
Monitor and he had a panic attack this
is when we were in Rockford Center and
he just said I'm out and he like he ran
towards the elevator and got on the
elevator and the segment producer Frank
Smiley chased him and and lost him but
then found him and there was a barred uh
on street level I think called Hurley's
that was uh and found him
so he made it just in time but the idea
that uh that I actually had a guest walk
before I even spoke to them was quite an
achievement what did you do what did you
say I think he just got really nervous I
think he saw me and said I can't talk to
that that crazy man with the pastry for
hair I can't talk to him so he ran away